hi
i'm cyron gianini welcome to clauderun
what's new
so a year ago we launched publicly cloud
run
in this session i'm gonna go i'm gonna
go over the few improvements that we've
released
since then this session will be
structured in three dimensions
we'll see how clodran is now even more
enterprise already
how it is more developer friendly
and how it gives you more flexibility
but first i want to recap what is
cloudrun
so cloudrun allows you to run containers
on a fully managed
environment we can call that serverless
its main characteristics are that it
auto scales
there is no infrastructure to manage and
it allows you to go
fast it makes you productive
so as i said you can deploy containers
in
seconds and thanks to that you can use
any languages
any library you want because of
containers
we spent a lot of time delivering an
enhanced
developer experience so that we make you
productive when using cloudrun
a few a few nice things is that when you
deploy to cloudran you get out of the
box an automatic https endpoint for your
service and you can attach your own
custom domain
very easily cloudrun
is portable first because it accepts
the container standard as an input but
also
because it is based on k native an open
source project that allows you to run
serverless workloads
anywhere and cloudant is also available
for enters
allowing you to run the same cloud-run
workloads on your in your own cluster
be it on google cloud on other clouds
or on-prem and finally cloud run
is pay-per-use you literally only pay
for when your containers are processing
requests rounded up to 100 milliseconds
so with that let's dive in let's see how
clogran
is now even more enterprise ready
so first when we launched a year ago
we launched to better and today we are
generally available of course that comes
with all of the goodness of a generally
available product of gcp
in term of support and in term of
service level agreement cloudron has
99.95 availability sla
then we've been very hard at work to
turn on cloudrun
in many different regions all over the
world
so what you see on that map are the
green dots are where clodron is
available
today and the blue dots is what we where
we plan to upload lord run
by the end of the year so as you've seen
we now cover all continents and and we
are
hard at work to turning up even more
regions very soon
then one of the key feature that we
added
that was requested by many of you was
the ability
to access your resources that are in
your vpc
in your virtual private cloud so for
example
thanks to serverless vpc connectors
cloudrun can now connect to cloud memory
store redis
or memcache or simply connect to private
ip of a compute engine vm for example
next we you know when we raise clodran
uh you could anytime you are deploying a
new
revision of a cloud on service this
revision was starting to serve traffic
as fast as possible
to 100 well we all know that's not
really how we
should deliver software right so
what we added is the capability to
control the rollout of your revisions or
even to roll back
to a previous revision so let's see an
example
of what we call a blue-green deployment
so let's assume
we are in a revision that we will call
blue and we want to deploy
to something called green so the first
step
is to of course deploy that new revision
so let's assume i want to deploy
a new image of my container so i would i
would use a regular command you would
know
except that this time i'm going to say
do not serve traffic
and i'm going to give it a tag green for
this example
of course i'm showing you this use the
command line but you can do exactly the
same from the cloud console
once i've done that this revision that
was created is not gonna serve traffic
but i as a developer or my team
can can give it a try can invoke it
under a very specific url that contains
the tag
that we just added so once i validated
that this new revision is ready to go is
behaving correctly
then it's time to send traffic to it
gradually
so i will start i will start small i
will start by sending one percent
of the traffic to that new revision so
in that case i'm using the update
traffic command and i'm going to say
send one percent
to the tag green and the system will
know that
the tag green is attached to a specific
revision and that one percent of the
incoming external traffic
should go to that new revision from my
end what i should do now
is take a look at my monitoring
dashboard my logs
filter by this revision name and double
check that everything is fine
once i confirm that everything is good
to
continue then it's time to send more
traffic to that revision
so i'm gonna send 10 percent wait a
little bit
double check everything is fine send 50
percent
wait a little bit check everything is
fine and finally
send 100 of the incoming traffic to that
new revision
by the way at google we mostly do our
graduate rollouts over four days
making sure that everything is healthy
between each steps
once i've done that i'm good to go this
new revision is serving all of the
incoming traffic and i consider this
that which is the new
current revision if at any point in time
during the rollout or at any point in
time
i can roll back to a previous revision
to do so it's one click in the user
interface or one command
with gcloud which is an update i update
the traffic but this time
to a specific revision name and i send
100 of the traffic to it
which means i'm going to roll back to
that revision
so hopefully that can help you mostly
safely release your your your container
and your software
uh by giving you more control and allow
you to traffic splits
between revisions all right
then um we added support for google
cloud artifact registry
so artifact registry is the evolution of
google cloud container registry and the
benefits of it
is that you can have container
registries
in very specific regions in the regions
you want
so that's even better to for data
locality so that you can store
your containers in wherever you want
you can even use your own encryption
keys to encrypt those containers in the
registry
cloud artifact registry has a free tier
which is always good
and you can have per repository access
control
using cloud iem so in the example on the
right what i'm doing
is that i'm deploying two cloud run from
artifact registry
uh where my registry is actually from
europe north one
a very specific region in europe
okay next in the enterprise-ready um
category we added support for
google cloud load balancing so what that
helps you do for example is that if you
deploy
the same cloud run service in three
different regions
you can add on top of them google cloud
load balancer
and expose a global endpoint that will
route requests
to the closest region
in order to reduce latency but also to
be resilient
to regional outages in case something
goes bad in a google cloud region
so let's see an example here somebody
from san francisco connects to my global
endpoint
well google cloud load balancer will
route that request to
my cloudant service which is in the us
but now if somebody from paris
connects to that same global endpoint
then google load balancer will send the
request
to europquest one so you see how you can
build
global services with increased
availability
and performances on top of multiple
cloud run services
but that's not all google cloud load
balancer allows you to use cloud cdn
so now by using cloud load balancer and
cloud cdn
on top of cloudran you can for example
reduce the load on your cloudband
service or increase performance
of your of your service so let's see
this example
the very first request comes in this one
you know is not cached because nobody
has seen it before this one will reach
the cloud run service
cloudrin can respond with a special
response header which is cache control
and
saying i want you to cache this request
for 300 seconds
good next time a client asked the same
cloud cdn will be able to return the
request without even
it's needing to reach your cloud on
service so you see how by
caching some um some requests you can
drastically reduce the load on your
service and performance
so that's not all uh google cloud load
balancer integration
gives us even more uh identity where
proxy
is something that allows you to add
basically a logging screen
on top of your cloud run service and
this logging screen can
enable you to grant access to only
certain
users inside your organization for
example your employee for
in in an internal application so once
again
i did your proxy via google cloud load
balancing
on top of cloud run and very similarly
you can use cloud armor thanks to google
cloud load balancing
so cloud armor is is a web application
firewall
um it will help you um
you know in case of a denial of a
service attack
and it will help you you know accept
only some
some ips from certain ip ranges or
geographies
so in this example on the right i am
only accepting ips from a range and the
others
gets rejected so
the the rejected ones don't even reach
my cloud and service that this is
all handled by cloud armor via google
cloud load balancer
so hopefully we are convincing you how
cloudant is even more than before
enterprise ready
with all of those very important
features that you've been asking us to
deliver
now let's see how clodran is even more
developer friendly
so first we've we've heard your feedback
and um
you know thank you for sharing that you
like cloud run
we measured via the some cloud console
surveys
uh that most of you are very satisfied
with cloudrun
and so um we are pleased to hear that
and this is one of the highest
satisfaction statistics on score that we
we've seen
for google cloud so we are very proud of
this but we haven't stopped
there we have we are keeping delivering
many developer focused features to make
you even more productive
and one of them is the ability to deploy
from a yaml file
so if you want to store the
configuration
of your cloudant services in your
version control system
in config files well you can and
actually because cloudant
implements the cognitive serving api
this file is exactly
a cognitive serving resource descriptor
so this is what with that you can
achieve what some
some people called called githubs which
is you use git
as your source of truth when it comes to
your resource configuration
so we've added a new command to gcloud
called gcloud
run services replace and that takes a
yaml file
of your service next
we've worked with the cloud code team to
bring clodran
integration inside the cloud code ide
plugins
for intellij and visual studio code
so this plugin will help you bootstrap
new
cloud on apps with sample apps it will
help you
manage your services and your revisions
see their properties
it will help you build your source code
into containers and deploy them to clone
run
and my favorite it will help you run
your cloud on services
locally inside a containerized
environment that looks a lot
what you would have if you deploy it to
cloud run
next we google cloud has released google
cloud
build packs so build packs are basically
recipes to create containers in very
in a set of very popular languages in in
our case
the google cloud build packs support go
nodejs python
java and dot net thanks to build packs
you don't need to
worry about writing dockerfiles anymore
if you see the example on the right
my source code doesn't contain any
dockerfile and i'm able to build it
with cloud build using the pack command
into a container that i can then deploy
to cloud run
build packs are you know those build
packs are open source and build packs
are
a cncf open standard um
that are used by many vendors so we are
very proud to
to have them today to help you build the
containers
next is that when you deploy to cloudon
and when you build your container from
from a git repository we now capture
the context of this container and
display that
right inside the user interface so if
you see on that slide
uh you see how in addition to the
container image url
we give you a link to the build that was
used
to create that container as well as a
link
to the github repository at this
specific commit
for you to troubleshoot in case
something is wrong with that particular
container
and on a similar fashion we are also
helping you embrace the best practices
of continuous deployment
so right now from the cloud and user
interface you can in a few clicks
configure a continuous deployment
pipeline for your cloud-run service
so let's take a look right now i'm
creating a new service
and i'm going to instead of picking a
specific container that i already built
i'm going to select a git repository
so when i click this it asks me to
authenticate with github if
github is where your git repositories
are
then i can select one of my repositories
i validate the build configuration
giving it
a location of my docker file and my
branch
i hit save and then clardon will create
the cloudron service as well as create a
cloud build
trigger that will automatically watch
this repository for new commits
and when they are pushed to this
repository will automatically build and
deploy
to cloud run so in that case we trigger
the first build
and your service is now serving um
with the code that was in your git
repository over time
we even show you um the history of the
builds
right inside the cloud user interface
for convenience
but that's not all what we've delivered
for developers
i'm very excited to say that we are
launching
new ways to trigger your cloud run
services
via events so basically you can now
trigger cloud services
when events are emitted from other
google cloud resources
so this is all based on cloud audit logs
so you might know that gcp resources
anytime they are changed or they emit
audi clogs so very easily what you can
do now
is you can trigger your clodron service
anytime one of your gcp resource
is is mutated and the events that you
receive
to your cloud and service are delivered
in an open standard again
the cloud event open standard which is a
cncf project
so i'm also very excited to say that we
are launching
cloud workflows so cloud workflows allow
you to
uh orchestrate your serverless tasks
in with a rich and declarative
model for example you want to process
events with multiple
cloud services you can chain api calls
you can automate infrastructure
management
you can implement retries policies very
easily thanks to cloud workflows
so in this example on the right uh what
i'm doing very simply is every day
i want to stop all of my developer
machines so to do that
every day at 6 00 pm one cloudant
service returns me a list of all of the
dev vms
another one extracts their statuses
and for each vm i extract the status if
it is running
i stop it and then i email the email
the owner of this vm to make sure that
tomorrow they don't forget to stop them
so you see how you can build complex
workflows
by bringing together very simple
serverless pieces
so that's it that's how we uh have made
cluttering even more developer friendly
over
the last month and we are not stopping
there of course
now let's see how we've uh we've heard
your feedback and we've
been removing some of the limits that
cloron had at the beginning by giving
you more flexibility
so first we heard you you want more ram
you want more cpus so you can now go up
to four gigabytes of
memory and four vcpus
on a very similar fashion in the past
you are limited to 15 minutes of request
processing time
we are now extending that to an hour so
you can process things up to one hour
on cloud run
next once again we are delivering
something that a lot of you
have been asking for um today
as i mentioned clodran scales autoscales
and notably scales down to zero so
that's great but that means that when
there is no traffic and suddenly there
is traffic that comes in
you have what we call a call start which
is the time it takes to
to start to go from zero container
instances to one container instances or
more
and this usually depends a lot on what
your container
is doing at startup time
with mean instances you can say hey i
want
a minimum of for example two instances
always one at any point in time and when
that's the case cloud1 will make sure
that you
you your num your number of instances
never goes below
this this specific the number you
specified
so that's great for improving
performances notably uh
when it scales down to zero but the good
news is that those instances
when they are not in used actually are
cheaper
than active instances another thing
we've added
um to help you better handled handle the
auto scaling of clutter
is that we are now sending a signal
before the instance is shutting down
so that gives you the time for example
to close any open database connection
or to send any data that you might not
have sent and kept in memory
by sending the sick term signal you have
up to 10 seconds of processing time
when you can do something before the
instance is shut down
we've also heard you we added support
for grpc so now out of the box
your cloud run service can expose a grpc
server
that you know nothing to configure just
your code has to start a grpc server
that listens on the same port as the one
we are sending
regular http requests so grpc on a
serverless infrastructure
yes that's possible with cloudrun
and lastly we've also heard your
feedback
we added support for server side
streaming
so what that means is that you can now
stream your responses
back to the clients you are not limited
anymore by the response size of
32 megabytes the responses are not
buffered anymore
that allows you to stream http and grpc
responses
in the example on the right what i'm
doing is my small web server is actually
serving a video file
to the client and i'm using this special
header transfer encoding
chunked that means that the client will
be downloading um
the stream of the bytes of this video
so hopefully uh this is removing some of
the limits
that were initially part of clauden and
don't worry we are not stopping here
we are we are keeping removing those
existing limits
so hopefully with that with this talk um
i convinced you
how uh claudine is now even more than
ever
enterprise ready and even more than ever
developer friendly and by removing some
of
its original limits gives you more
flexibility
we've been very hard at work to deliver
all of these features
that last year and we are of course
not going to stop here i want to thank
you for
um attending this session and we can't
wait to see
the great things you will build with
cloudrun
you